that bumbling nincompoop Donald Trump
who's a total rube and doesn't know
anything and only accidentally became
president anyway just gave one of the
top ten speeches in presidential history
at the United Nations we will analyze
the Donald's moral clarity then Brett
Kavanaugh is guilty until proven
innocent
Michael Moore's movie bombs Cruz gets
run out of a restaurant and the GOP is
more popular than it's been in years
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
oh do we have a lot to get to today
oh is this just superb I was up you know
this speech wasn't that long ago I
watched the whole thing I'm gonna go
through it if you haven't seen it we
will go through it point by point it was
one of the great presidential speeches
which is why the UN audience absolutely
hated it before we get to that we have
to thank our wonderful sponsor and you
know I couldn't watch this speech
without them I couldn't open my eyes in
the morning without them black rifle
coffee National Coffee Day is coming up
September 29th you know what is gonna be
in my morning mug black rifle coffee
mixed in with some nice little helping
of leftist tears some people like cream
some people like 2% milk I put in left
his tears and it's very delicious
sort of in americano black Rifles coffee
club makes things easy you just pick
your blend the amount that you want
black rifle ships your coffee right your
door every month you don't need to worry
about it you don't have to run out of
coffee like I always would do especially
when I was single it is great it's roast
to order Durrington you fresh delicious
coffee with every order I love these
guys the most important thing number one
is that they make excellent coffee
that's actually all I care about with my
coffee and they really really do after
that I love it because they you know
they're tied in with veterans causes
first responder causes it's just great
it's pro America they've got a beautiful
gun right on their on their logo it is
great right now have is a black rifle
coffee calm slash cough FAC of V Fe Fe
get 15% off your order you will not
regret it it will become your favorite
coffee as it has mine black rifle coffee
calm / go FFA Co V Fe Fe don't worry
about you know all of that those other
coffee stores that look like homeless
shelters now good black rifle coffee
calm / coffe FA Co V Fe Fe let's get
right into it
we don't have enough time to dance
around it here president Trump at the
United Nations General Assembly I really
I know that people say that he is stupid
even people on the right say this that
he's stupid he's a bumbling idiot
he just gets lucky or whatever maybe
he's stupid but the only argument
against that is that he just keeps
getting every
thing right this speech was flawless and
you know how you know that is they
laughed at him and they mocked him and
they jeered him and he even joked about
it here as president from getting
laughed at at the UN my administration
has accomplished more than almost any
administration in the history of our
country America's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
so he says my administration has
accomplished more than almost any other
administration which is true I mean he
had very low expectations to begin with
but everything has gotten better under
his watch and in some cases better at
record highs joblessness the stock
market Foreign Affairs have been handled
very ably protection of rights expansion
of freedom deregulation it's all going
really really well but they laugh at him
now it's very impressed with president
khofifah here because typical president
coffe FA was just like start you just
turn around and moon the entire audience
if they like screw you guys who cares
what you think but he actually handled
it with a little bit of charm he said oh
okay didn't think I get that reaction
here that's okay
and then he launches into this speech I
don't know who wrote this speech I
suppose it could have been Steven Miller
apparently he writes a lot of these
great speeches whoever it was deserves
an award it got everything exactly right
the diction was beautiful the priority
of the prioritization of policy was
beautiful it just struck all the right
notes at all the right time so let's get
into it here is President Trump on
global governance to the UN itself each
of us here today is the emissary of a
distinct culture a rich history and a
people bound together by ties of memory
tradition and the values that make our
homelands like nowhere else on earth
that is why America will always choose
independence and cooperation over global
governance control and domination I
honor the right of every nation in this
room to pursue its own customs beliefs
and traditions the United States will
not tell you how to live for work or
worship we only ask that you honor our
sovereignty in return from Warsaw to
Brussels to Tokyo to Singapore it has
been my highest honor to represent the
United States abroad
you hear that you hear they're not
laughing now they're not they were just
laughing oh ha ha ha Oh Donald ha ha ha
ha ha but they're not laughing now the
first thing I want to point out because
a lot of people on Twitter that all the
headlines all the news headlines are
President Trump gets laughed at at the
United Nations and they say this is so
embarrassing this is consider who's
laughing consider the people who are
laughing first of all some of the most
horrific countries on earth Venezuela
Iran those guys are ok they're laughing
ha ha ha who else is laughing people in
the European Union people whose defense
we pay for people that we're defending
who else is laughing people that we give
money to in foreign aid
who else is laughing people who would
take away the rights of their citizens
and of citizens around the world to
govern themselves that's who's laughing
great I hope that I hope those guys
would laugh at me
I really hope they'll laugh at me and
they're not laughing now when he gets
into this they're not laughing this
isn't gonna be some fluffy eccentric
speech he is laying this out very
clearly the United States will resist
global governments global governance by
bodies specifically like the United
Nations and the International Criminal
Court and all you know there is a
movement right now around the world
especially in Europe to pull away from
these supranational institutions and
organizations that take away people's
rights to govern themselves Trump isn't
using Trumpy language here he's not
using colorful language he is getting
right to the heart of it and they are
listening so that he talks about the
global governance he stands up and for
all intents and purposes says the UN is
a dystopian fantasy and now that it's a
wonderful great nice dream idea that
it's a it's a bad fantasy because it
takes away the rights of people to
govern themselves and he he has the
courage to go to the UN and say for all
intents and purposes we oppose you and
then he gets into specifics because the
way that this point of view is
caricatured is that oh he's an
isolationist the u.s. is going to
retreat its going to ignore the
international community the rest of the
world is going to go forward we're gonna
say no no no we're going to allow
atrocities to happen but this view the
view of this administration whether it's
Trump's view or not it is now because
he's articulated
is that we is it's much more nuanced
than that here I'll let him explain it
in this vein we urge the United Nations
led peace process be reinvigorated but
rest assured the United States will
respond if chemical weapons are deployed
by the Assad regime you hear that it's
not they can do whatever they want
oh let Russia do whatever they want let
us saw do whatever they want no it isn't
that he's saying the peace process in
the UN wants to keep going on that's
what we won't interfere with that we're
not going to make it our national
priority to rebuild a country in Syria
or to institute regime change or to do
any of these pie-in-the-sky Wilsonian
endeavors in Syria but there is a moral
minimum said look you don't have to
choose between total isolation and
nation-building you can have a moral
minimum here which says we're gonna let
this keep going on we're going to not
impose an entirely impose from right
above Western liberal democracy on Syria
but but if the regime in Syria uses
chemical weapons in violation of
international treaties it like a butcher
in a bloodbath
we will intervene we will interview I
not trying to intervene but if you make
us intervene we will we will insist upon
a moral minimum in the international
order if you don't meet that moral
minimum we will take your country away
it will at least hit you pretty hard if
you do meet that moral minimum you can
govern yourself in peace unmolested by
us this is a nuanced view and it's this
is the steel man this is the serious
view that Trump's critics on the left
and the right the Wilsonian 's and the
isolationists it won't acknowledge which
is that there there is a middle ground
that respects the sovereignty of nations
then he goes on into the refugees and
this is where the this is where
demagogues also on the left in the right
one I hit him and this is where the
nuance of this position is so clear and
the people of Jordan
and other neighboring countries for
hosting refugees from this very brutal
civil war as we see in Jordan the most
compassionate policy is to place
refugees as close to their homes as
possible to ease their eventual return
to be part of the rebuilding process
this approach also stretches finite
resources to help far more people
increasing the impact of every dollar
spent notice the language we appreciate
people who are taking in refugees in
neighboring countries countries like
Jordan or wherever because this issue
gets demagogued they say oh if Europe
will not allow itself to be flooded by
young Muslim men from failed States who
haven't been vetted from Syria from
Afghanistan from wherever then if you
don't allow that then you're not
compassionate then your wicked then your
evil your unchristian your on Western
your unliberated s or that it's same
thing in the United States Barack Obama
wanted to flood the country with
refugees from Syria we said why they
have to come here why on earth would
they go from Syria pass through all the
neighboring countries get into Eastern
Europe Western Europe cross the Atlantic
Ocean go to the United States why is how
is that the solution how are you
unchristian if you think that maybe
that's not the most efficient way to
care for these people why but there are
vested political interests in making
that happen there are vested political
interests by the left by the advocates
of World Federation by the advocates of
global governing bodies like the United
Nations who want that to happen because
they want to erase for all intents and
purposes national boundaries President
Trump is saying no I'm not going to let
you call me anti refugee or anti
compassionate or whatever I think that
these people should be taken care of we
should support efforts to take care of
them but it doesn't mean they have to
flood countries that are thousands and
thousands and thousands of miles away it
doesn't make any sense and he makes a
good point there at the end he said
there's nothing efficient about that if
we
dollars our charity dollars to go as far
as they can help as many people as they
can
why would we be flying all of these
people over to the United States when
going you know thousands of miles
through Europe when we could help them
in neighboring countries and then he
strikes that point home he says they
need to be in those neighboring
countries so that they can rebuild their
country when the Civil War is over and
he's calling their bluff
because all the the Pro immigration Pro
refugee people say look where else are
they going their countries are under
attack
they just need it they're refugees they
just need a temporary place to go well
okay but if they're gonna go to a
temporary place why bring them to
America it's much harder to get back of
course what their real purpose is is to
bring them all to the west bring them
all to the United States have them
become American citizens in large
numbers and in disregard the will of the
American people whether or not they want
that many refugees that many unvetted
people that those that culture that
comes from a war-torn area to come to
the United States oh you can't do that
and they demagogue on the issue and they
say if you don't permit that then you're
you you're not living up to your own
values which nobody else lives up to but
also your your unchristian those values
that undergird our civilization you know
the Cardinals bishops have said this you
have to welcome all of the refugees
welcome all of the refugees and
President Trump is being very nuanced
here he's saying we would like to help
them we want to help them in the way
that is best suited for their interests
and for their nations and for their
countries and what does the Left say to
that they have nothing that they can say
to that it totally exposes the lie which
is that it's not about helping refugees
from a particular civil war it's about
transforming the makeup of Western
countries in the United States then he
gets into Iran and now you know Barack
Obama made Iran the pinnacle of his
foreign policy he was willing to give
away everything he had and a lot of
things that he didn't have to secure the
Iran deal which for all intents and
purposes put Iran on the path to get a
nuclear weapon
president Trump singles out Iran but the
reason he singles out Iran is not just
cuz they're bad guys
they are bad guys it has everything to
do with the nation-state with
nationalism with the international order
here's him calling out Iran every
solution to the humanitarian crisis in
Syria must also include a strategy to
address the brutal regime that is fueled
and financed it the corrupt dictatorship
in Iran Iran's leaders so chaos death
and destruction they do not respect
their neighbors or borders or the
sovereign rights of nations so listen to
that they don't respect borders they
don't respect the sovereign rights of
nations he points out that they're bad
guys and they're brutal and they're all
of this but there are a lot of brutal
regimes around the world there are
plenty of brutal regimes and over the
course of history brutal regimes are the
norm they're not the exception so what
makes it Ron so awful is that Iran
undermines the international order in
the system of nation-states that we've
had for 350 years Iran has always done
since the Iranian Revolution decades ago
they try to keep one foot in the
international order and one foot out so
they'll speak at the United Nations
they'll send their heads of state to
speak at Columbia University they have
different agreements with other
countries they'll sign on to fake
treaties with the United States under
Barack Obama they'll demand money
they'll demand to be treated as though
they're serious players in the
international community and then they'll
fund Hezbollah then they'll fund Hamas
and then we'll fund there's enough on
this no no fun man no fun terrorists all
around the world the largest state
sponsor of Terror around the world and
undermining the the boundaries of other
countries really fighting with us during
the Iraq war
oh why would we tolerate this why could
we tolerate this country having one foot
in one foot out either you're in to the
system of nations or you're out of it
we've had the system of nations now for
350 years we'll explain that and explain
why it's so important in a second
because President Trump concludes his
speech with a rousing call to defend it
but even institutions like the United
Nations in many ways undermine this by
tolerating countries like Iran by
tolerating supernational instead
students that remove the sovereignty of
independent nations so he's calling them
out for that people shouldn't get
confused he's talking about Syria and he
says you know you better watch out Assad
because we'll get you if you'd cross a
line but he really singles out Iran as
being wrong per se as being unfit for
the world order per se and it's because
of how they behave with regard to
nationalism then lest you think that
he's only beating up on Foreign Affairs
in the Middle East only tackling the
most complex issues still has decades
then he defends his stance on trade and
I hope that conservatives listen to this
for decades the United States opened its
economy the largest by far on earth with
few conditions we allowed foreign goods
from all over the world to flow freely
across our borders yet other countries
did not grant us fair and reciprocal
access to their markets in return even
worse some countries abuse their
openness to dump their products
subsidize their goods target our
industries and manipulate their
currencies to gain unfair advantage over
our country beautiful because a lot of
conservatives now are saying Donald
Trump is anti free trade there's nothing
in that statement that makes its him
sound anti-free trade he's not saying
that the problem was that we opened up
our markets to foreign goods he's saying
the problem is we didn't get their
markets in return which is what people
who have been defending this policy of
threatening tariffs have been saying for
a while which is that this is we never
had free trade we never had really free
trade before free trade is a wonderful
thing but people are not playing by the
rules just to take China alone they
steal our intellectual property they are
manipulate their currency and this is
not something that Donald Trump just
started talking about I was on Jon
Huntsman's campaign in the early days of
that campaign in 2012 and he was a
hardliner he was running in many ways
like a tea party candidate and he was
saying we need to force China about
which he knew a lot because he was the
ambassador to China he said we need to
force them to stop manipulating our
currency and stealing our IP now
president Trump is actually following
through on this putting a lot of
pressure on China and conservatives are
attacking him but previously before the
Trump era there was widespread agreement
on this from virtually all flanks of the
Republican Party from the conciliatory
nice tone you know more elite end of the
party all the way to the populist and
there was a consensus that you need to
force people to play fairly on trade now
they're attacking him as though he
doesn't know anything about economics
though the strength of our economy right
now would seem to suggest maybe those
experts are the ones who are mistaken
this is such an important point and it
also points out that first the logic of
the the trade war and the the trade
threats it should be simple to everyone
but I will spell it out we say tariffs
are always wrong don't ever institute
any tariffs don't ever retaliate against
tariffs one of the main arguments
against tariffs is that they will start
a trade war but why will they start a
trade war because it is expected that
rational nations when they have tariffs
imposed on them when they have unfair
trade conditions imposed on them will
respond in kind
but if tariffs are always in every case
there's no use for even threatening
tariffs then why would that be the case
the argument for tariffs or the argument
rather against tariffs undermines the
argument against threatening tariffs
arrogance trying to play fairly and the
way he articulated that is beautiful he
didn't get up and say we're never doing
trade with any other countries we're
making everything here screw you rest of
the world he didn't say that at all he
said you've got to play fair and he said
it right to their face right in the
General Assembly then we move on to the
John Bolton of it all I was waiting for
President Trump to rip his mask off show
that giant walrus mustache and you know
have put the glasses on in the big glass
ring and just have John Bolton screaming
at them did you miss me boys
did you miss me it's been a while huh he
takes on the International Criminal
Court here it is for similar reasons the
United States will provide no support
and recognition to the International
Criminal Court as far as America is
concerned the ICC has
jurisdiction no legitimacy and no
authority the icc claims near universal
jurisdiction over the citizens of every
country violating all principles of
justice fairness and due process we will
never surrender America sovereignty to
an unelected unaccountable global
bureaucracy America is governed by
Americans we reject the ideology of
globalism and we embrace the doctrine of
patriotism around the world responsible
nations must defend against threats to
sovereignty not just from global
governments but also from other new
forms of coercion and domination
beautiful what this does the United
States didn't have to articulate this
policy John Bolton articulated it and
spelled out what the State Department
was going to do about it
a few weeks ago at the Federalist
Society he said the ICC is dead the
International Criminal Court which is
going to go in and try to prosecute
American soldiers they're dead to us we
will take every action against them that
we have to take but president Trump
chose to under underline this today at
the UN that's beautiful because it means
that it has the support not just of the
wonks and the State Department whatever
it has the full support of the President
of the United States it's the official
policy of the President George Bush when
he was president talked about this as
well pulled us out of talks for the ICC
and Donald Trump is underlying a
beautiful thing and he says we will
pursue a policy of patriotism we will
not submit to this submit is the key
word because I think a lot of people on
the left they think oh the ICC sounds
great
oh there's a there's an international
super national body hovering above us
all and they're gonna hold everyone to
justice all the bad guys around the
world
why wouldn't we support that the United
Nations it's it's United it's United why
would you want you don't want to be you
want to be divisive you want to be the
divisive nations oh it's so nice oh the
in a union there you know yeah to whom
are these international organizations
accountable to whom to you the voters to
you Americans to you the people who hold
our values and have our culture and
believe what we believe were they're
responsible to Venezuela or they're
responsible to North Korea or they're
responsible to Iran or they're
responsible who to whom are they
responsible to what ideas you know
different countries have different ideas
different cultures have different ideas
which ideas are going to govern them and
what recourse will you have against them
if they start treating you unfairly if
they start targeting you if they started
pressing you no recourse whatsoever who
votes for the United Nations do you get
to vote you don't get to vote no
absolutely not but we demand as citizens
of this country that we have the right
to govern ourselves that's how we run
our country that's the way it is Donald
Trump is underlining that and he's
exposing the shallow saccharine
sentimentality of these international
bodies for what it is then he gets to
the heart of it one of the main central
issues of his campaign and one of the
central issues pushed by the Pro
international Pro Imperial bodies like
the United Nations immigration
recognized the right of every nation in
this room to set its own immigration
policy in accordance with its national
interests just as we ask other countries
to respect our own right to do the same
which we are doing that is one reason
the United States will not participate
in the new global compact on migration
migration should not be governed by an
international body unaccountable to our
own citizens absolutely right because if
immigration is governed by that then you
don't have a country
because when because the point of
immigration in self-governing countries
and democratic republics such as we have
is that they make the laws so the
country who controls immigration for a
Democratic Republic controls the country
that's how it works
you flood it with enough people who
think a certain way they're going to
elect a government and you know
have any power that's the way it is
maybe you'll get lucky maybe the end of
the all-star voting for Republicans but
maybe they won't and very likely the any
immigration policy that would affect
that probably won't happen as a Catholic
this does present an interesting point
which is that the system of nations the
Westphalian system is largely a product
of Protestants it happened at the Treaty
of Westphalia in 1648 because the
Catholics could not reclaim Empire the
Spanish Empire or the Holy Roman Empire
that couldn't reclaim it ironically it
was affected by Catholic Cardinal
Richelieu of France in many ways he was
he was the guy who ensured that six or
seven years after his death the
Westphalian system would go into place
but now we find ourselves defending that
system why is that because who are these
empires accountable to if they were
accountable to God if they were Catholic
empires they were accountable to God
himself maybe I could get behind it but
to whom is the UN looking for spiritual
and political and moral guidance god
only knows God help us if we get that
answer or the International Criminal
Court wherever you can't trust any of
these international bodies Trump says
that exactly right and if you control
immigration if an if an outside force
controls immigration into a country it
controls the country as long as that
country holds Western values which
coincidentally all of our countries do
then he hits Venezuela specifically just
to remind you that a lot of people in
this room are dirty rotten scoundrels
currently we are witnessing a human
tragedy as an example in Venezuela more
than 2 million people have fled the
anguish inflicted by the socialist
Maduro regime and its Cuban sponsors not
long ago Venezuela was one of the
richest countries on earth today
socialism has bankrupted the oil-rich
nation and driven its people into abject
poverty
virtually everywhere socialism or
communism has been tried it has produced
suffering corruption and decay
socialism's thirst for power leads to
expansion incursion and oppression all
nations of the world should resist
socialism and the misery that it brings
to everyone
I don't think trumps are real
conservative to you I don't think he's
not a real conservative he's like a big
lefty he's not a real conservative I
mean he just gave a speech that would
make Ronald Reagan blush but he's not
four he's very not a real conservative I
wish that they could cut for reaction to
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes when he just
goes after socialism and make no mistake
he's hitting socialism abroad he's
hitting Venezuela is hitting these awful
socialist countries but he is hitting
the Democrats who have embraced
socialism who are running over 40
candidates formally identified with the
democratic socialists of America this
year and he's saying socialism is misery
it's awful
cut to Ocasio Cortez Lee I'm not the
expert I'm not really the expert on any
I know you're not the expert so he hits
socialism really hard because it's awful
it's terrible national socialism is
awful you know the Nazis international
socialism is awful the you know a USSR
and democratic socialism is awful it's
insidious
it's evil there's no argument for it
it's very bad it's a little slower it's
more gradual it's more pernicious it
doesn't seem as awful up front but it is
the exact same poison the gospel of envy
the philosophy of failure as Winston
Churchill said just terrible why is that
because eventually it's a contradiction
in terms
the reason that it's a con it's not it's
certainly the case that you can elect
socialists you can elect as a free
people to have socialist programs to
have an ever increasing government
controlling more and more of your lives
but you can't remain democratic for very
long because of a problem of human
nature which is the more power you give
to these corrupt institutions that the
less recourse you're going to have a
government that's big enough to give you
everything you want is big enough to
take away everything
you have this has always been the case
socialism has failed inbred misery and
slavery everywhere that it's been tried
in some cases that has progressed more
slowly in some cases has been very very
fast but we've seen it everywhere the
American left is never apologized for it
they continue to embrace it and Trump is
smacking it down it's beautiful and
delightful finally he brings it home on
with a note on patriotism that is very
beautiful Donald take us home we must
defend the foundations that make it all
possible
sovereign and independent nations are
the only vehicle where freedom has ever
survived democracy has ever endured
where peace has ever prospered and so we
must protect our sovereignty and our
cherished independence above all
absolutely beautiful I have one little
criticism of that bit which is he talks
about peace prospering only in the
nation-states he's half right but he's
half wrong because there has been peace
before you can add as Ronald Reagan said
you can have peace in two seconds which
is to say the word I surrender if you
say I surrender you'll get peace in two
seconds slavery is peace it's peaceful
for a little bit there was peace in the
Roman Empire there have been peace and
other empires peace and parts of the
British Empire there have been a lot of
empires in the world a lot of since
antiquity Empire the natural inclination
of man is Empire as your Amazon II who
we had on the show a couple weeks ago
talks about the Bible calls out the
nation of Israel to be a nation and to
be a light of to other nations God
speaks to Israel says be a nation don't
be an empire be a nation we are a nation
the modern system of the world is
represents nation states and nations
might not always be totally peaceful but
they will be free now President Trump
look it sounds nice to say peace
prospers and it is true by the way if
your government is oppressing you
there's a certain peace to that but
there's a certain violence to that too
there's actually a certain constant
violence to that too but the speech was
superb the nation-state is the only
vessel
for freedom and prosperity he's
absolutely right it's true materially
it's true spiritually it's true
politically in this day and age perhaps
at some other time the world wasn't in
that position but right now that is the
case there is no good empire to which I
would give my sovereignty a wonderful
speech it's his best speech since Warsaw
that was another wonderful speech of his
and probably written by the same guy
touched on a lot of the same themes
really really good he should give more
of these just excellent they say that
he's a nincompoop he doesn't read he
doesn't know anything he talks about
stormy Daniels he goes and sees porn
stars
I don't care Donald take all the porn
stories you want if you give speeches
like that and you give it to the rest of
the world like that
and you defend American freedom like
that have them all take that every every
penthouse pet every playboy of the month
I don't care wonderful and the media are
gonna report this like a bunch of fools
which is what they are they're gonna say
he got laughed at that's gonna be the
headline that you see but you saw that
speech you heard those statements that's
a beautiful thing that's what we stand
for as Americans and we should defend it
tooth and nail by the way at the end of
that speech at the end of that speech I
wish I had the clip he ends it by saying
by thanking the glory and goodness of
God and says to all in those words and
then says to them god bless you all
because what he is saying is that our
system of nations our respect and desire
for human freedom is based on the God
that created us and not just any vision
of God not some little devil God that
some guy out there believes him but the
true the one and true God on which this
international order is based beautiful
wonderful statement they say he's a
lapsed Presbyterian who doesn't go to
church doesn't really bother me doesn't
bother maybe it bothers him maybe he
should talk to his God about that but if
he is speaking so bluntly so clearly and
so precisely about our nation states
about our country about the values that
our country is based on and the God who
gives us those values one more power - a
wonderful speech we have a lot more to
get to unfortunate I gotta say goodbye
to Facebook and YouTube ironically it's
national voter registration day give you
some thoughts on that and I don't think
it's ironic I guess it's coincidental
the president Trump is defending
right of Nations to govern themselves
then we've got to talk about Brett
Kavanaugh who's guilty until proven
innocent we've got that wacko from
Hawaii mazie Hirono Cruz gets run out of
a restaurant and some good news I'll
leave you on some good news by the way
I'm not gonna be here tomorrow folks I'm
flying over to Ohio to talk to all of
the brilliant students at Franciscan
about the simple joys of being right if
you're in the area maybe I'll see you
there if not hopefully we'll be able to
get it online or something like that
that's gonna be the first speech in my
young America's Foundation tour
Kofi Fay on campus which is coming to a
school near you hopefully if you'd like
if you'd like to bring a little co FFA
to your campus go to ya dot org and you
can request that I come give a speech
there if you're not on telly wire.com go
do it freedom isn't free folks and
neither is Telecom so spend ten bucks a
month $100 for an annual membership you
get me get the under flaming sure you
get the Ben Shapiro show you guys
questions in the mail bag which I will
be answering coming up this week get
your questions in that doesn't matter
because you get the UN vintage baby
leftist tears and you better get it now
soon because there I think there are
already plans in place to build the
Donald Trump Presidential Library on the
bulldozed ruins of the UN building on
the east side of Manhattan so make sure
you get your leftist here's you and
vintage tumblr soon because well you
know that pretty soon they're gonna be
gone and you're not gonna get any of
that salty deliciousness
go to daily wire.com be right back
it's national voter registration day
this is a fake holiday that was invented
in 2012 but it's a wonderful coincidence
because Trump just gave an entire speech
about how you vote you get to determine
the course of your country and some
Joker's at The Hague or in Brussels or
at the United Nations don't get to do
that for us I would like a little public
service announcement for national voter
registration day please listen closely
well if you're listening to this show
this won't be a problem but tell your
friends if you do not know anything
about or have any stake in history or
the government or the public debates of
this country don't vote don't vote don't
vote don't there's nothing good about
voting if you don't know anything it's
actually bad to vote if you don't know
anything do not do it if you have no
stake in the country if you don't like
the country if you don't like your
countrymen don't vote don't vote it's a
bad idea to vote then why would you
remember a few years ago when Puff Daddy
did that campaign of like voter died cuz
I'm gonna kill you if you don't vote
don't worry he's old now he's not gonna
he's not gonna hurt you anymore
don't vote if you do know something go
vote and don't forget guys don't forget
Election Day is coming up Election Day
is coming up this November if you if
you're a Republican election day is this
November if you're a Democrat Election
Day is in December so mark that on your
calendar Circle December is I gotta go
vote in December I don't want to miss it
and if you're and then closures were
saying if you're a Republican it's in
November it's I don't listen what I just
it's November
just a little PSA for a national voter
registration day okay Brett Kavanaugh
that dirty rotten murderous genocidal
rapist maniac NBC told me is guilty
until proven innocent
so this is what they've all been saying
they've been saying a bunch of and not a
bunch really just a few of these
Democratic activists who say that a guy
who looked like Brett Kavanaugh walked
by them in 1942 and they're saying that
he's unfit for the court because of that
the ones who are making these absurd
sexual allegations that have no
corroboration whatsoever that people who
are called witnesses in them have been
and said they don't exist the stories
have been changing year-over-year women
have been changing their stories coming
out of the woodwork Brett Kavanaugh has
solid defenses for all of these things
the left is saying he's guilty until
proven innocent here is a mess LSD I
believe isn't isn't that what rush calls
that no he calls that P MSNBC that's
even in any case MSNBC speaking to the
senator from Hawaii
mazie Hirono you're there do you believe
that Brett Kavanaugh should deserve or
does deserve the same presumption of
innocence in your response was that you
put his denial in the context of
everything you know about him in terms
of how he approaches his cases I'm sure
you're aware that in conservative
circles there is some outrage some anger
at your comment listen to that did you
hear that is she said she said yeah you
know so you said that he's guilty until
proven innocent and I know Cuba we have
to talk about this but in certain
conservative circles they think it's bad
to be guilty until proven innocent
dummies know our country is founded on
the basis our country depends upon the
basis that you are innocent until proven
guilty not the other way around
and Elizabeth MSNBC's lady I don't know
her name is talking to senator Hirono as
though this were weird she's actually
admitting that only conservatives have
standards of justice and then the left
like we do we would do we bulldoze all
of them if we got into power and then
listen to Maisy's response
do you believe judge Kavanaugh does
deserve a presumption of innocence or
not look we're not in a court of law
we're actually in a court of credibility
at this point and without having the the
FBI report or some semblance of trying
to get corroboration we are left with
the credibility of the two witnesses
corroboration of what did you just hear
what you said you said we so she made
this fake dichotomy we're not in a court
of law we're in a court of credibility
which is a court of law is a court of
credibility right so it's just one of
those things that politicians of both
sides do this where they say like
country over party you're like right I'm
in the party to help my country dump
down it's the same thing they're not
dichotomies but but so she says that
whatever fine she's a politician but
then she says you know look
without any corroboration of these bogus
ridiculous claims that are being refuted
left and right by everybody named in
them
we've just got to believe the accusers
that know so the way it works
nazy is if you don't have corroboration
then you don't believe the acute
accusations then you don't believe the
accusers because there's no
corroboration for them
does she know what corroboration means
does she know what credibility means she
uses these words and she has no idea
what they mean by the way is it not a
miracle it's probably cuz he's at the UN
and he's distracted but that the
president has not started calling her
crazy amazing her name was built for a
trump nickname and if she is like the
only person that doesn't have one yet I
am sure by the time this show airs today
he'll already pick calling her that
really outrageous but they're being
honest good on them for being honest
which is saying we want to bulldoze
standards of justice we don't support
the rights of the accused especially if
there were old white guys or middle-aged
white guys in the case of brick Avenue
we don't want any of that good that's
okay that's what they're offering up in
in November and this isn't going to play
very well for them did you see what
happened to Ted Cruz at that restaurant
last night here it just very quickly Ted
Cruz and his wife were sitting at a
restaurant they were having you know a
nice dinner and then a bunch of
mainstream Democrats came in and behaved
as mainstream Democrats are behaving in
2018
we believe survivors except for Karen
Monahan and 28a Broderick and all the
others if they were abused by Democrats
but we believe random people who come
out of the woodwork when Brett Kavanaugh
a virgin until after high school is up
for the Supreme Court that was that that
was too long so they had to change it
too we believe survivors who they don't
believe oh my gosh I wish I could say
that these were wacko lefty lunatics
it's not they're not they're not all of
these this was the top trend on Twitter
yesterday we believe survivors none of
these women by the way have have a
accused and you want a rape nothing
you're not even like the wackiest
explanations have involved rape but
that's what they say we believe sir we
believe so okay so they chase him out of
this restaurant and and
there's this guy on Twitter he's a
transgender activist named Charlotte
climber who said he tweeted out he said
well you know bado O'Rourke has never
gotten chased out of a restaurant yeah
because his opponents aren't hysterical
children like the Democrats are right
that yeah we don't do that I'm very
proud to say we don't do that but this
is so they scream at Ted Cruz and all
this is not gonna play well we have so
much more to get to but unfortunately
we're running late so I will skip to
this point because you know a lot of us
are wondering how all of this is going
to affect the midterm elections which
are coming up again Democrats they're
coming up in December and closure is for
a second and Republicans they're coming
up in November so how is this going to
affect the election according to Gallup
polling which leans left it's not a
right-wing polling firm the GOP is more
popular than it's been in seven years
you wouldn't know that if you just
listen to those shrieking little
children at the restaurant you wouldn't
know that if you were listening to MSNBC
you're reading the New York Times or The
Washington Post or blablablablabla but
but they the GOP the Republican Party
not even just Trump who's also doing
well but the GOP is the most popular
it's been in seven years they've made
those are the
ability is 45% Democrat favorability
according to Gallup is 44% the
Republicans are more favorable more
favor will be viewed right now than
Democrats this this is up for
Republicans from 36% last year this is a
major gain by the way since 2008 since
since the election of Barack Obama
Democrats have almost always rated
higher and often significantly higher in
favorability than Republicans now you
would say now a lot of people watching
the news would say now Republicans have
they've never been less popular oh it's
all off let's go into hell in a
handbasket
no way Republicans are historically
popular you won't read about it in the
New York Times you won't see it on NBC
but it's true there have been major
gains in the last few months oh but what
about stormy Cavanagh whatever muller or
whatever oh it really should have
declined right no it hasn't the part of
the reason for that jump is that the GOP
right now is more likely to view their
own party favorably but the Democrats
view of the GOP has not declined it
hasn't diminished a lot of people say
yeah well okay the GOP Republicans might
be viewing their own party more
favorably but they're totally losing
Democrats and people on the fence not
true that's not reflected in Gallup
polling Democrats view the GOP and the
Democrat then their own party the
Democrats in exactly the same way as
they did GOP has seen a jump among
people of all economic groups and
especially middle class income earners
why is that because they've managed the
economy very very well this is very good
news it tells me not to believe the
polls very much because the the generic
election polls of for instance one
because there's no such thing as a
generic candidate people are voting for
their own candidates and because a lot
is not reflected when when you inject
Trump into questions a lot of numbers
get skewed and also you know when you
call different when you call up
different people polling has had a
number of crises in the last year's
because of methods of collecting
information but these numbers in so much
as we can look at the polls these
numbers are really pretty good and if
President Trump keeps going up there and
offering a choice not an echo not being
Democrat light not being UN light not
but going out there and go
after them in defending American
interests which are in the interests of
the world for America to follow American
interests I could see great popularity I
could see being surprised in November
because it's true historically we should
lose the house maybe we will lose the
house but I I could see a real surprise
now if they back down if the Democrats
go squishy if Chuck Grassley doesn't
hold this damn vote if if Republicans
cave I could see a blue tidal wave
coming and taking us all the choice is
up to our elected officials but at least
one of our elected officials today
handled himself very very well okay
that's our show I got to get out of here
I won't see you tomorrow unless you're
in Ohio then I will see you I look
forward to going out there in the
meantime I am Michael Knowles this is
the Michael Nolt show I will see you
again on Thursday
[Music]
the michael noland is produced by seniya
Villarreal executive producer Jeremy
bori senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018